>>> RIHANNA HAS BEEN SHOWING OFF
HER BABY BUMP AND SEXY MATERNITY
LOOKS AT PARIS FASHION WEEK.
HERE TO COMMENT IS PAULINE, A
WEARY MOTHER IN HER DARKEST
HOUR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO BELIEVE
IT, MICHAEL.
I'M PREGNANT AGAIN.
>> WELL, HOW ARE YOU DOING,
PAULINE?
CONGRATULATIONS.
MUST BE SUCH AN EXCITING TIME.
>> EXCITING FOR WHO, MICHAEL?
LAST TIME I GAVE BIRTH THE BABY
WAS SO BIG THE DOCTOR SAID HE
LOOKED LIKE BLACK JASON MOMOA.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT FIELDS LIKE TO
DROP A DROGO?
BAD.
BUT HERE, LOOK AT RIHANNA.
COME ON.
WITH A PERFECT CUTE LITTLE BABY
BUMP.
MEANWHILE, I LOOK LIKE I'M
TRYING TO SHOPLIFT A TURDUCKEN.
I'M JUST REGULAR PREGNANT.
I WANT TO BE FAMOUS PREGNANT.
>> FAMOUS PREGNANT?
THAT WAS JUST RIHANNA'S
PREGNANCY ANNOUNCEMENT PHOTO,
RIGHT?
>> SURE WAS.
RIHANNA AND HER BOYFRIEND ALL
HAPPY.
WALKING AROUND HARLEM.
YOU KNOW HOW I ANNOUNCED MY
PREGNANCY?
I THREW UP ON MARTIN LUTHER KING
JR. BOULEVARD.
YOU KNOW, I'VE HAD BABIES BEFORE
BUT THIS IS MY WORST PREGNANCY
YET.
IT'S MAKING ME WANT TO EDIT AALL
KINDS OF THINGS.
PICKLES, PEANUT BUTTER, THE
BARREL OF A SHOTGUN.
>> PAULINE.
>> I DON'T MEAN IT.
I DON'T MEAN IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
PREGNANCY BRAIN.
>> WELL, RIHANNA HAS BEEN
WEARING SOME ICONIC PREGNANCY
LOOKS AT FASHION WEEK.
HOPEFULLY TO INSPIRE OTHER
PREGNANT WOMEN.
>> OH, PLEASE.
LOOK AT THIS, MICHAEL.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE'S GOING TO A
SEX FUNERAL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND SHE MAKES IT LOOK GOOD.
HOW?
I COULDN'T EVEN WEAR THIS
BEFORE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO WEAR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
EVERYTHING'S GOT TO STAY PUT.
YOU KNOW?
BUT RIGHT NOW EVERYTHING ON ME
IS LOOSE, INCLUDING MY PUSHER.
SHE'S ALWAYS WEARING HEELS.
YOU WANT TO SEE MY HEELS,
MICHAEL?
THESE.
I USED TO WEAR A SIZE 9.
NOW I'M A MEN'S 15.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU KNOW I EVEN GOT MY TUBES
TIED.
BUT THEY CAME LOOSE.
I KEEP BEGGING MY DOCTOR, DOUBLE
KNOT THEM NEXT TIME, PLEASE.
>> THEY TIED THEM LIKE
SHOELACES?
>> LOOK, I'M OUT HERE ON MY OWN,
MICHAEL.
AT LEAST RIHANNA'S GOT A
BOYFRIEND BY HER SIDE.
MEANWHILE, YOU HAVEN'T COME WITH
ME TO NOT ONE DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WAIT, WHY WOULD I?
>> BECAUSE YOU DID THIS TO ME.
>> I DID?
>> MM-HMM.
I SAID LET'S USE PROTECTION.
AND YOU LOOKED ME IN THE EYE AND
SAID "IT DON'T FEEL THE SAME."
>> THAT DOES SOUND LIKE ME, YES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALL RIGHT, YOU KNOW, I'VE GOT
TO GO.
I LEFT MY KIDS IN LORNE'S
OFFICE.
>> PAULINE, EVERYBODY.
>> I'M YOUNGER THAN RIHANNA.
I'M ONLY 29.
For "Weekend Update," I'm
Colin Jost.
>> I'm Michael Che. Good night.